why you should create a GK autopilot
cluster GK autopilot makes it easier to
own and run kubernetes clusters using
gke one way to think about it is that I
prefer to or rather can only drive my
car in automatic transmission now most
cars have an industry standard interface
so I know how to use it immediately like
a steering wheel and if my priority is
to get where I'm trying to go I want
this interface to handle as much as it
can for me automatically and yes this
includes having to manually shift gears
similarly in gke autopilot rather than
manually owning the process of creating
configuring and managing nodes all of
that is handled for you while still
giving you the industry standard
kubernetes API that way you can focus on
what's most important to you your
workloads if you're like me and want to
make time for what's most important when
using gke check out the tutorial Linked
In the pinned comment where you'll see
for yourself